the old Chester CREB is supposed to be
one of the things that I really like
about playing this character is he is
thrown into these extraordinary
circumstances shrinking flying around my
hands
entering quantum realms and
life-threatening stuff one thing that
we've always tried to sustain is dealing
with everything with a little bit of us
as a few right we have a lot of tricks
in this movie that the audience hasn't
seen before you will see ant-man size
action and giant size action and you may
see a lot of different size action in
between I get Jeff how was school today
and then you have wasp she's someone
that we've never seen in action on
screen and that's been great in terms of
figuring out how she moves how she
fights how she flies
you gave her wings and blasters so I
take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
there's so much action and the stakes
are so high
immediately the minute that we introduce
the character of ghost the game changes
what's up to so long she just wanted to
give me a hug wish me luck
really mad moment things don't stop
moving
wish I had a suit even with like minimal
powers or maybe even just a suit with no
powers no